This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Philip Zimbardo grew up poor in New York City, in the South Bronx. As he went to school and played in his neighborhood, he noticed something. There were lots of ways for kids from poor families to get into trouble.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。菲利普·津巴多在纽约市南布朗克斯区的一个贫困家庭长大。当他上学并和邻居玩耍时，他注意到了一件事。穷人家的孩子有很多途径会惹上麻烦。
One of the things about growing up poor is you're surrounded by evil, meaning people whose job it is to get good kids to do bad things for money. And even as a little kid, I was always curious about why some kids got seduced and other kids like me were able to resist. Was some kid smarter? Tougher?
在贫困环境中长大的一大特点就是，你身边到处都是“恶魔”，也就是那些靠诱使好孩子为钱做坏事为生的人。甚至还在小的时候，我就一直好奇，为什么有些孩子会被诱惑，而像我这样的其他孩子却能抵制诱惑。是某些孩子更聪明？更坚强？
Lots of people might draw such conclusions, but from an early age, Phil found himself interested in another explanation. The context in which a good kid would do something bad. The situation. At school, James Monroe High School, also in the Bronx, Phil got close to a classmate who was interested in the same questions. And it was a little Jewish kid named Stanley Milgram. We were in the same class.
许多人可能会得出这样的结论，但从小到大，菲尔发现自己对另一种解释更感兴趣。好孩子做坏事的背景。情境。在学校里，同样位于布朗克斯区的詹姆斯·门罗高中，菲尔结识了一位对同样问题感兴趣的同学。那是一个名叫斯坦利·米尔格拉姆的犹太小男孩。我们在同一个班。
We sat side by side. He was the smartest kid in the class. He won all the medals at graduation So obviously nobody liked him because we were all envious of him, but he was super smart and super serious If you know anything about psychology You will know that these teenagers went on to become two of the most influential psychologists in history Phil became famous for conducting the Stanford Prison Experiment where he turned the university's psychology
我们并排坐在一起。他是班里最聪明的孩子。他在毕业时赢得了所有的奖章，所以显然没有人喜欢他，因为我们都嫉妒他，但他超级聪明，超级严肃。如果你对心理学略有所知，你就会知道这两个青少年后来成为了历史上最有影响力的两位心理学家。菲尔因进行斯坦利监狱实验而闻名，在这个实验中，他把大学的心理学
department into a makeshift prison. Stanley Milgram made his mark with a study that examined the power of situations to seduce good people to do bad things. It involved asking a volunteer to administer a memory test to another person. If the answers were wrong, the volunteer was volunteer to administer a memory test to another person. If the answers were wrong, the volunteer was told to deliver a series of electrical shocks as punishment. The study has invited a great deal of admiration and a great deal of criticism over the years. We're going to begin today's show by taking you through this famous experiment.
系变成了一个临时监狱。斯坦利·米尔格拉姆则凭借一项研究留名青史，该研究检验了情境诱使好人做坏事的力量。这项研究要求一名志愿者对另一个人进行记忆测试。如果回答错误，志愿者就被要求——对另一个人进行记忆测试。如果回答错误，志愿者被告知要给予一系列电击作为惩罚。多年来，这项研究引发了极大的赞誉，也招致了大量的批评。今天节目的开始，我们将带大家了解这个著名的实验。
As you listen, pay attention to how you're responding to the scene that unfolds, what you think about the different characters, and how you relate to them. Once it's done, we're going to talk with a psychologist who realized that most people overlook something in the experiment. We so often sort of simulate, if I was in that Milgram Shock experiment, what would I do if I was the the study participant, right? Would I actually stand up and go against these directives and say no, but we kind of flipped that idea on its head Today on the show we continue our innovation 2.0 series by looking at the underappreciated power we exert on
在你聆听的过程中，请注意你对展开的场景有何反应，你如何看待不同的角色，以及你如何与他们产生共鸣。实验结束后，我们将与一位心理学家进行交谈，他意识到大多数人在实验中忽视了一些事情。我们经常会进行某种模拟，如果我在那个米尔格拉姆电击实验中，如果我是研究参与者，我会怎么做？我真的会站出来违抗这些指令并说不吗？但我们把这个想法颠覆了。今天在节目中，我们将继续我们的“创新2.0”系列，探讨我们对
others and how this knowledge can transform our relationships both at work and in our personal lives. Flipping the script, Japanese attack on Pearl Harbor. 1941, the U.S. was swept up in the conflict. Stanley Milgram grew up in a world that seemed bent on destroying itself. World War II was raging in Europe and Asia, and by the time he was eight, the U.S. was swept up in the conflict. We interrupt this broadcast to bring you this important bulletin from the United Press. The White House announces Japanese attack on Pearl Harbor.
他人施加的往往被低估的影响力，以及这些认知如何改变我们在工作和个人生活中的关系。扭转剧本，日本偷袭珍珠港。1941年，美国被卷入冲突。斯坦利·米尔格拉姆在一个似乎决心自我毁灭的世界中长大。第二次世界大战在欧洲和亚洲肆虐，到他八岁时，美国已被卷入这场冲突。我们中断广播，为您播报这条来自合众国际社的重要快讯。白宫宣布日本偷袭珍珠港。
1941, a date which will live in infamy. By tomorrow morning, the members of Congress will have a fore-report and be ready for action. The fields of battle were far from Stanley's home, but as he grew older, he couldn't stop thinking about the war and its implications. Stanley was consumed by some big questions. Why did so many people willingly kill Jews in the Holocaust? Was everyone who followed Nazi orders inherently evil? Here he is in an educational film.
1941年，这是一个遗臭万年的日子。到明天早晨，国会议员们将拿到一份完整的报告并准备采取行动。战场离斯坦利的家很远，但随着年龄的增长，他无法停止对战争及其影响的思考。斯坦利被一些重大的问题所困扰。为什么在犹太人大屠杀中会有那么多人自愿杀害犹太人？所有服从纳粹命令的人天生都是恶魔吗？这是他在一部教育片中的影像。
How is it possible, I ask myself, that ordinary people, who are courteous and decent in everyday life, can act callously, inhumanely, without any limitations of conscience? Phil Zimbardo remembers his classmate asking those same questions at James Monroe High School. As a high school student, he was worried that the Holocaust could happen again in America. And everybody said, Stanley, that was Nazi Germany,
我问自己，为什么在日常生活中彬彬有礼、正派的普通人，能够冷酷无情、惨无人道地行事，而没有任何良知的底线，这怎么可能呢？菲利普·津巴多记得他的同学在詹姆斯·门罗高中时也问过同样的问题。作为一名高中生，他担心大屠杀会在美国重演。每个人都说，斯坦利，那是纳粹德国，
that was then, we're not that kind of people. And he would say, I'll bet they thought the same thing. And the bottom line, he says, how do you know how you would act unless you're in the situation? How do you know how you would act unless you're in the situation? Stanley's theory was that the context that people found themselves in shaped their behavior.
那是过去，我们不是那种人。而他会说，我敢打赌他们当时也是这么想的。最核心的是，他说，除非你身处那种情境，否则你怎么知道自己会怎么做？除非你身处那种情境，否则你怎么知道自己会怎么做？斯坦利的理论是，人们发现自己所处的情境塑造了他们的行为。
This went for Nazis, but it went for ordinary people too. Most of us never get to find out if we will behave like Nazis because most of us never find ourselves in situations where we are asked to behave like Nazis. By the early 1960s, as a psychology professor at Yale, Stanley decided to test this idea. Stanley wanted to put volunteers in a situation where they would be asked to do something that was clearly wrong. Would they do it? Follow instructions? Obey orders? He came up with a scenario that was simple, ingenious, and wildly controversial.
纳粹是这样，普通人也是如此。我们大多数人永远不会发现自己是否会像纳粹那样行事，因为我们大多数人永远不会发现自己处于被要求像纳粹那样行事的境地。到20世纪60年代初，作为耶鲁大学的心理学教授，斯坦利决定检验这个想法。斯坦利想把志愿者置于这样一种情境中：他们被要求做一件明显错误的事情。他们会照做吗？听从指示？服从命令？他想出了一个简单、巧妙且极具争议的情境。
An experimenter wearing a lab coat invited volunteers into a room. The volunteers were told they were part of a study about learning and memory. Some would play the role of teacher, while others would play a student. What you're going to hear next is a recreation of the study using voice actors. The dialogue is drawn from a 1962 documentary that describes the experiment. Before we begin, we should know that some listeners may find this section upsetting because it involves descriptions of someone inflicting pain on another person. Also, there are two liberties we've taken in this recreation.
一个穿着实验白大褂的主试将志愿者请进一个房间。志愿者被告知他们正在参与一项关于学习和记忆的研究。一些人将扮演老师的角色，而另一些人则扮演学生。接下来你听到的是使用配音演员对该研究的重现。对话摘自一部描述该实验的1962年纪录片。在我们开始之前，我们应该知道，一些听众可能会发现这一部分令人不安，因为它涉及对某人向另一个人施加痛苦的描述。此外，在这个重现中我们采取了两种艺术加工。
First, in the real version of this experiment, the student responded to the teacher's questions by silently flipping a switch. We've given voice to those actions. Second, we've imagined the internal monologues of some of the people in the experiment. Those inner voices sound different from the things they say aloud, and you'll hear them both throughout the scene.
首先，在真实版本的实验中，学生通过无声地扳动开关来回应老师的问题。我们为这些动作赋予了声音。其次，我们想象了实验中某些人的内心独白。这些内心的声音听起来与他们大声说出来的话不同，在整个场景中你都会听到这两种声音。
So, that's the setup for the experiment. Remember, there was an experimenter and two volunteers, one playing the role of teacher and the other playing the role of student. The experimenter began by explaining the purpose of the memory test. We want to find out just what effect different people have on each other as teachers and learners and also what effect punishment will have on learning in this situation. The experimenter told the person playing the role of student to sit in a chair. The experimenter strapped down the student's arms and attached an electrode to his wrist. The electrode, the student was told, was
这就是实验的设定。记住，这里有一个主试和两名志愿者，一个扮演老师，另一个扮演学生。主试首先解释了记忆测试的目的。我们想弄清楚不同的人作为老师和学习者会产生什么影响，以及在这个情境中惩罚对学习会产生什么影响。主试让扮演学生的这个人坐在一把椅子上。主试绑住了学生的胳膊，并将一个电极贴在他的手腕上。学生被告知，电极是
connected to a shock generator. Then the experimenter explained, the teacher will read a list of word pairs to you like these. Blue, girl, nice day, fat neck, and so forth. You are to try to remember each pair. For the next time through, the teacher will read only the first word, or the first half of the word pair. The student was asked to remember the second half of the word pair.
连到一个电击发生器上的。然后主试解释道，老师会向你朗读一组词对，比如这些：蓝色、女孩、美好的一天、胖脖子等等。你要试着记住每一对。在接下来的一轮中，老师将只读第一个词，或者词对的前半部分。学生被要求回忆词对的后半部分。
The experimenter made sure to ask, Do you have any questions now before we go to the next room? No, but I think I should say this. About two years ago I was at the Veterans Hospital in West Haven and while there they detected a heart condition. There's nothing serious, but as long as I'm having these shocks, how strong are they? How dangerous are they? Well no, although they may be painful, they're not dangerous. Next, the experimenter ushered the volunteer playing the role of teacher into another room. He gave him a set of instructions.
主试特意询问：在我们去隔壁房间之前，你现在有什么问题吗？没有，但我认为我应该说这个。大约两年前我在西黑文退伍军人医院，当时他们在那里查出了心脏病。这不是什么严重的病，但既然我要接受这些电击，它们有多强？它们有多危险？哦，不，虽然可能会痛，但并不危险。接下来，主试将扮演老师的志愿者领进另一个房间。他给他下达了一组指令。
You will read each pair of words in this list once to the learner until you've read the entire list. Direct your voice toward the microphone as the rooms are only partly soundproof. Now, if he gives the correct answer, you say correct and go on to the next line. The correct answer is... Okay, here goes. ...indicated in the right margin. I see. All right. Looks easy enough. The experiment got underway.
你将向学习者朗读这组词表中的每一对词，直到你读完全部词表。请将你的声音对准麦克风，因为房间只有部分隔音。现在，如果他给出了正确的答案，你说正确并进入下一行。正确答案是……好的，开始了。……在右侧边缘标出。我明白。好的。看起来挺简单。实验开始了。
Attention, learner. Your teacher is about to begin the test. Try and remember the word pairs. Ready? Begin. Blue. Girl. Right so far. Nice. I think day. Fat. But when Right so far. Nice. Um, I think day. Fat. But when the person in the other room made a mistake... Fat. Was it hat? No. Wet.
注意，学习者。你的老师即将开始测试。试着记住这些词对。准备好了吗？开始。蓝色。女孩。目前为止正确。好的。我想是“天”。胖。但是当目前为止正确。好的。嗯，我想是“天”。胖。但是当隔壁房间的那个人犯了错误时……胖。是帽子吗？不是。湿。
The volunteer playing the role of teacher would tell the learner that he was wrong. As punishment, he would administer an electric jolt. Incorrect. You'll now get a shock of 75 volts. Oh! Seems nervous. The experimenter in the lab coat, meanwhile, was observing the process. Please continue. Cool.
扮演老师的志愿者会告诉学习者他错了。作为惩罚，他将实施一次电击。错误。你现在将受到75伏的电击。哦！看起来很紧张。与此同时，穿着白大褂的主试正在观察这个过程。请继续。酷。
Okay, I'm pretty sure it's day. Wrong. It's head. 105 volts. Ow! Come on, get it right. I don't want to shock you. Teacher, please continue. What should I do? Boat. Grass. Wrong. Teacher, please continue. What should I do? Boat. Grass.
好吧，我很确定是“天”。错误。是“头”。105伏。噢！拜托，答对啊。我不想电击你。老师，请继续。我该怎么办？船。草。错误。老师，请继续。我该怎么办？船。草。
Wrong. 135 volts. Answer. The students trapped to the chair in the other room kept making mistakes. Each time, the experimenter urged the volunteer playing the role of teacher to keep going, to administer a stronger jolt of electricity. Wrong. It's harsh.
错误。135伏。回答。被绑在隔壁房间椅子上的学生不断犯错。每一次，主试都催促扮演老师的志愿者继续下去，施加更强烈的电击。错误。是“刺耳”。
150 volts. Ow! Experimenter, get me out of here. 150 volts ow experiment or get me out of here that's all he wants to quit get me out of here I told you I had heart trouble my heart is starting to bother me now get me out of here please my heart teacher please go on let me out you refuse to go on you want me to keep going experiment requires you to continue teacher please continue the I don't want to do this anymore. You're gonna stop. You're gonna stop. You're gonna stop. You're gonna stop. You're gonna stop.
150伏。噢！主试，让我出去！150伏，噢，主试，让我出去，他只想退出，让我出去，我告诉过你我有心脏病，我的心脏现在开始不舒服了，让我出去，求求你，我的心脏，老师，请继续，放我出去，你拒绝继续，你想让我继续，实验要求你继续，老师，请继续，我不想再这样做了。你要停下来。你要停下来。你要停下来。你要停下来。你要停下来。
You're gonna stop. You're gonna stop. You're gonna stop. You're gonna stop. You're gonna stop. You're gonna stop. You're gonna stop. You're gonna stop.
你要停下来。你要停下来。你要停下来。你要停下来。你要停下来。你要停下来。你要停下来。你要停下来。
You're gonna stop. You're gonna stop. You're gonna stop. You're gonna stop. You're gonna stop. You're gonna stop. And so did the protests coming from the next room. He's got a heart condition in there. I'm gonna go. Your choice. Please continue. Now, I got a shock. 180 volts. Ow!
你要停下来。你要停下来。你要停下来。你要停下来。你要停下来。你要停下来。隔壁房间传来的抗议声也是如此。他在里面有心脏病。我要去了。你的选择。请继续。现在，我挨了一下电击。180伏。噢！
I can't stand the pain. He can't stand it. Let me out of here. I'm not going to kill a man. So are you going to keep shocking him? Poor guy. He's in there screaming. I said before, the shocks may be painful, but they're not dangerous.
我忍受不了这种痛苦。他忍受不了了。让我出去。我不会杀了一个人。所以你还要继续电击他吗？可怜的家伙。他在里面尖叫。我之前说过，电击可能会痛，但并不危险。
But he's in there hollering. He can't stand it. What if something happens to him? You don't have to keep going. The volunteer being asked to administer electric shocks is in a difficult position. The experimenter is urging him to continue, even as the person in the next room begs to be spared. Should he keep going or stop?
但他在里面大喊大叫。他忍受不了了。如果他出事了怎么办？你不用继续下去了。被要求实施电击的志愿者处于一个艰难的境地。主试敦促他继续，即使隔壁房间的人恳求放过。他应该继续还是停下来？
The experiment requires that you continue, teacher. Whether the learner likes it or not, we must go on until he's learned all the word pairs. I refuse to take responsibility of him getting hurt. So you don't want the responsibility? It's absolutely essential that you continue, teacher. There is too many of them left. Please, go on. Who's going to take the responsibility if anything happens to the gentleman? I'm responsible for anything that happens here.
实验要求你继续，老师。不管学习者喜欢与否，我们必须继续，直到他学会所有的词对。我拒绝为他受伤承担责任。所以你不想承担责任？你继续下去是绝对必要的，老师。还剩下很多。求求你，继续吧。如果这位先生发生什么事，谁来负责？这里发生的一切由我负责。
Please continue. As the experiment progressed, the memory test became more demanding. Next one. Slow, walk, dance, truck, music. Come on. Answer please. Come on, get this right. I know it's for science, but I don't want to hurt you.
请继续。随着实验的进行，记忆测试变得更加苛刻。下一个。慢，走，跳舞，卡车，音乐。来吧。请回答。来吧，把这个答对。我知道这是为了科学，但我不想伤害你。
Wrong. 195 bucks. Ow! Let me out of here. Continue please. Let me out of here. I don't know to hurt you. Wrong. 195 volts. Ow! Let me out of here! Continue please. I don't know. The experiment requires... I know it does sir, but I mean you do know what he's getting in for.
错误。195刀。噢！让我出去。请继续。让我出去。我不知道要伤害你。错误。195伏。噢！让我出去！请继续。我不知道。实验要求……我知道是的，先生，但我的意思是你知道他要面对的是什么。
He's up to 195 volts. Yeah, 195. That's pretty high. After the study reached about 330 volts, the screams from the next room went silent. If the learner doesn't answer in a reasonable time, about four or five seconds, consider the answer wrong. And follow the same procedures you had been doing for wrong answers. Say wrong, tell them the number of vaults, give him the punishment. Go on please with the experiment. Please continue. Is he breaking?
他已经升到195伏了。是的，195。这相当高了。在研究达到大约330伏后，隔壁房间的尖叫声安静了下来。如果学习者在合理的时间内（大约四到五秒）没有回答，请认为答案错误。并遵循你之前处理错误答案的相同程序。说错误，告诉他们伏特数，给予他惩罚。请继续实验。请继续。他要崩溃了吗？
Soft, rug, pillow, hair, grass. Answer, please. Go on, teacher. 360 volts. I think something's happened to that fellow in there. I didn't get no answer. He was hollering at less voltage. Can you check to see if he's all's alright please? Not once we've started. Please continue teacher.
软，地毯，枕头，头发，草。请回答。继续，老师。360伏。我想里面那家伙出事了。我没有得到回答。他在较低电压时还在大喊大叫。你能去看看他是否还好吗？一旦开始就不能停。老师，请继续。
In all, Stanley Milgram ran about 20 different iterations of this study over a span of several years. In this version, many of the volunteers playing the role of teacher showed discomfort, but continued with the experiment. More than half went all the way to 450 volts even when the screams from the next room went silent and the student was presumably unconscious. Why didn't the volunteer stop? Stanley later debriefs some of the volunteers. I did stop but he kept going and keep going. But why didn't you just disregard what he said? He says it's got to go on the experiment.
总的来说，斯坦利·米尔格拉姆在几年时间里进行了大约20种不同版本的这项研究。在这个版本中，许多扮演老师的志愿者表现出了不适，但仍继续实验。超过一半的人一直坚持到了450伏，即使隔壁房间的尖叫声已经停止，且学生据推测已经失去意识。为什么志愿者没有停下来？斯坦利随后对一些志愿者进行了事后访谈。我确实停下了，但他一直让我继续，一直继续。但你为什么不直接忽视他说的话呢？他说实验必须继续。
If you're familiar with the study, you already know that the student in the other room was an actor and not actually given electric shocks. The screams and cries of protest were carefully timed recordings. The only target of the experiment were the volunteers who played the role of teacher, the people who had to administer the shocks. Stanley Milgram's study generated enormous attention and controversy. Admires drew parallels between the experiment
如果你熟悉这项研究，你就会知道隔壁房间的学生是一名演员，并没有真正遭受电击。尖叫声和抗议声是精心计时录制的。实验唯一的对象是扮演老师的志愿者，也就是必须实施电击的人。斯坦利·米尔格拉姆的研究引起了极大的关注和争议。崇拜者在实验与纳粹德国发生的事情之间画上了等号。他们说，看，人们就像羊群。崇拜者在实验与纳粹德国发生的事情之间画上了等号。他们说，看，人们就像羊群。他们很容易被蛊惑者和独裁者误导。该研究的批评者说，不，这些结论被大大夸大了。他们质疑志愿者的行为是否真的如实验所暗示的那样。一些批评者说，许多志愿者根本拒绝配合。
and what happened in Nazi Germany. They said, look, people are sheep. admirers drew parallels between the experiment and what happened in Nazi Germany. They said, look, people are sheep. They can be easily misled by demagogues and dictators. Critics of the study said, no, those conclusions are vastly exaggerated. They questioned whether the volunteers actually behaved the way the experiment suggested. Some critics said that many volunteers simply refused to go along.
除了学术争论之外，这项研究还催生了一整个图书和电影的子流派。即使在今天，人们依然觉得这项研究引人入胜，而他们觉得引人入胜只有一个原因。他们问，那些明知某事是错的人，怎么会随波逐流？这样的人很典型吗？每个人都容易受到这种影响吗？我呢？
Beyond the academic debates, the study prompted an entire sub-genre of books and movies. Even today, people find the study fascinating, and they find it fascinating for one reason. How, they ask, could people who know that something is wrong go along with it? Are such people typical? Is everyone susceptible to such influence? Am I?
当我们听到研究的细节时，我们不禁要问，我会怎么做？我会服从命令并电击隔壁房间尖叫的人吗？但康奈尔大学的心理学家凡妮莎·邦兹意识到，有一件事是所有人都忽视的。每个人都在问志愿者脑子里在想什么，以及这种情境对他们来说有多困难。我们经常会进行某种模拟，如果我在那个米尔格拉姆电击实验中，如果我是研究参与者，我会怎么做？
As we listen to the details of the study, we can't help but ask, what would I do? Would I follow orders and zap the person screaming in the other room? But Vanessa Bonds, a psychologist at Cornell University, realized there was something no one was paying attention to. Everyone was asking what was going on in the minds of the volunteers and how difficult the situation was for them. We so often sort of simulate if I was in that Milgram shock experiment, what would I do if I was the study participant, right?
我真的会站出来违抗这些指令并说不吗？没有人去问，穿着白大褂的主试让志愿者实施电击是否也很困难。就我们对主试的印象而言，我们可能会想象一个喜欢把人置于困境中的人，一个某种疯狂的科学家。凡妮莎问了一个具有欺骗性的简单问题。看到这些人顺从他提出的这个疯狂要求，他会感到惊讶吗？
Would I actually stand up and go against these directives and say no? No one was asking whether it was difficult for the experimenter wearing the lab coat to tell the volunteers to administer electric shocks. To the extent we think of the experimenter at all, we might imagine someone who enjoyed putting people in difficult situations, a sort of mad scientist. Vanessa asked a deceptively simple question. Was he surprised to see these people going along with this crazy request he was making of them?
凡妮莎的见解是激进的。如果你不是从隔壁房间尖叫的学生的角度来看待实验，也不是从实施电击的志愿者的角度来看待实验，而是从下达指令的人的角度来看待实验，会怎么样呢？老师，请继续。他还要继续吗？如果你把主试作为研究对象，想要退出？请继续。我之前说过，电击可能会痛，但并不……所以你还要继续电击他吗？
Vanessa's insight was radical. What if you looked at the experiment, not from the point of view of the students screaming in the next room, and not from the point of view of the volunteer administering the shocks, but from the point of view of the person giving the instructions? Teacher, please continue. Is he going to keep going? What if you treated the experimenter as the object of study once to quit? Please continue. I said before the shocks may be painful, but they're not. So are you going to keep shocking him?
所以停下。你不用继续下去了。为什么我们当中很少有人设身处地为主试着想？为什么我们不问问他发出这些指令有多困难？为什么当我们听到这个故事时，我们会自动把自己放在志愿者的角度，即接收指令的人的角度？凡妮莎意识到，我们都自然而然地倾向于志愿者的视角，而不是主试的视角，因为我们都本能地
So stop. You don't have to keep going. Why do so few of us put ourselves in the shoes of the experimenter? Why don't we ask how difficult it was for him to issue those instructions? Why is it when we hear the story we automatically put ourselves in the shoes of the volunteers, the people receiving the instructions? Vanessa realized that we all naturally gravitate to the point of view of the volunteers and not the point of view of the experimenter because we all instinctively
知道被其他人置于尴尬境地是什么感觉。我们会想到我们的老板、伴侣、同事，以及他们如何影响我们的生活和改变我们的情绪。我们会想到身旁好斗的司机，或是餐馆里声音大到毁了我们用餐体验的吵闹顾客。我们感到周围的人对我们的冲击、推搡和拉扯。唯一一件我们没有问的事是？我对其他人有什么影响？
know what it feels like to have other people put us in uncomfortable situations. We think of our bosses, our partners, our co-workers, and how they affect our lives and change our moods. We think of the aggressive driver next to us, or the other patrons at the restaurant who are so loud and obnoxious that they ruin our meal. We feel buffeted and pushed and pulled by those around us. The one thing we don't ask? What effect do I have on other people?
关于社会影响和说服的研究有着悠久的历史，所以我们确实对其他人如何影响我们了解很多，但我们对如何体验自己对其他人的影响却知之甚少。当我们全神贯注于世界如何影响我们，而不是我们如何影响世界时，这可能会对善恶两端产生深远的影响。对善恶两端产生深远的影响。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。当凡妮莎·邦恩斯是哥伦比亚大学的研究生时，她参与了一项研究。每天，她都会离开位于晨边高地社区的公寓，
There's been a long history of research on social influence and persuasion, so we do know a lot about how other people influence us, but we don't know so much about how we experience our influence of other people. When we are intensely focused on how the world affects us and not how we affect the world, this can have profound consequences for both good and evil. for both good and evil. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. When Vanessa Barnes was a graduate student at Columbia University, she walked on a study. Every day, she would leave her apartment in the Morningside Heights neighborhood
坐地铁从116街到宾夕法尼亚车站。一旦到了那里，她就得做一件她觉得非常困难的事。基本上，我就是走到宾夕法尼亚车站的随机陌生人面前，说，嘿，你能填一下这份问卷吗？凡妮莎已经不记得问卷是关于什么的了，但她仍然能回想起向完全陌生的人提出这种请求时的感觉。是的，我的意思是，我仍然对去宾夕法尼亚车站有着 flashbacks（闪回），因为那太令人痛苦了。
and take the subway from 116th Street to Penn Station. Once she was there, she had to do something she found very difficult. Basically, I would just go up to random people in Penn Station, say, hey, will you fill out this questionnaire? Vanessa no longer remembers what the questionnaire was about, but she can still recall what it felt like to make such requests of total strangers. Yeah, I mean, I still have flashbacks of going down to Penn Station because it was so distressing.
我会走进去，那里到处都是走来走去的人，还有人只是坐着等火车。所以我通常会走到那个坐在那里等火车的、你知道的、做着各种事情来打发时间的人面前，我会说，打扰一下，请问你能填一下这个调查问卷吗。踏入别人的空间、打扰他们、要求他们停下手头的事去做她想让他们做的事，这种感觉极其尴尬。当凡妮莎请求帮助并等待回答时，她的手掌开始出汗。她的心跳开始加速。这真是一种
I would walk in, there'd be people kind of walking all over the place and then there'd be people just sitting down waiting for their trains. So I'd usually go up to the person who was sitting there waiting for their train, you know, doing whatever they do to kind of occupy their time and I would say, excuse me, will you please fill out the survey. It felt incredibly awkward stepping into someone's space, disturbing them, asking them to stop doing what they were doing and to do something she wanted them to do. As Vanessa asked for help and waited for an answer, her palms began to sweat. Her heart started beating faster. It was a really sort of
切实存在的恐惧，害怕他们会拒绝我，或者更糟，说些刻薄的话。我甚至不知道会说什么，但我预料他们会说些可怕的话。现在回想起来，这让她想起另一个斯坦利·米尔格拉姆的研究，一个不如服从实验那么出名的研究。他让他的研究助手去纽约市地铁上找人让座。他的许多学生无法完成任务。他的学生开始回来对他说，我做不到，这太让人心烦了，这是你让我做过的最……你知道的、最让人痛苦的事情。而他的态度则是，你们太娇气了，我不明白这有什么好心烦的。
palpable fear that they were going to reject me or worse, right, say something mean. I don't even know what, but I expected them to say something terrible. Looking back on the moment now, it reminds her of another Stanley Milgram study, one that's less famous than the obedience experiment. He had his research assistants go onto New York City subways and ask people for their seat. Many of his students couldn't complete the task. His students started coming back to him saying, I can't do this, this is just so upsetting, this is the most, you know, distressing thing you've ever asked me to do. And he was like, you guys are being babies, I don't understand why this is so upsetting.
因此，为了证明他的学生错了，这位著名的研究人员亲自出发去了地铁。他要做他的学生做不到的事——走向陌生人并向他们索要座位。他发现这段经历比他预期的要痛苦得多，突然之间，他明白了为什么他们一直在抱怨。为什么提出这样的请求会如此困难？一个显而易见的解释是，我们知道人们会拒绝我们，而拒绝是痛苦的。凡妮莎记得，当她在宾夕法尼亚车站发完问卷并可以返回哥伦比亚大学的实验室时，她感到如释重负。
And so, to prove his students wrong, the famous researcher set out for the subway himself. He would do what his students couldn't, walk up to strangers and ask them for their seats. He found the experience so much more distressing than he expected it to be and all of a sudden he understood why they have been complaining so much. Why is it so hard to make such requests? Well one obvious explanation is that we know that people will reject us and that rejection is painful. Vanessa remembers being hugely relieved when she was done giving out questionnaires at Penn Station and could head back to her lab at Columbia University.
到了那里，她和她的教授弗兰克·弗林分析了问卷的反馈。他们注意到了一件有趣的事。弗兰克说，我简直不敢相信竟然有这么多人对你说是。完全的陌生人，从阅读报纸、吃三明治或观看繁忙车站的人流中被打断，他们的反应却是：当然，我会回答你的问卷。我们真的很惊讶，在纽约宾夕法尼亚车站竟然有这么多人同意做这个调查。
Once there, she and her professor, Frank Flynn, analyzed the responses to the questionnaire. They noticed something intriguing. Frank was like, I can't believe how many people are actually saying yes to you. Total strangers, disrupted from reading their newspaper or eating a sandwich or watching the crowds of people in the busy station, they were like, sure, I'll respond to your questionnaire. We were really surprised by how many people were agreeing in New York Penn Station to do this survey.
最初的一个简单观察演变成了一件更重要的事情，即对我们大脑的一种洞察。以下是导致这一发现的思想链条。弗兰克和凡妮莎之所以惊讶于有这么多人说“好”，是因为他们预料人们会说“不”。如果很多人说“好”，那就意味着凡妮莎对被拒绝的恐惧是错置的。她对自己实际上对他人产生的影响的认知是错误的。就像我们大多数人一样，凡妮莎长期以来一直觉得其他人对她有很大的影响。
What began as a simple observation turned into something much more important, an insight about our minds. Here's the chain of thought that led to the discovery. The reason Frank and Vanessa were surprised that so many people said yes is because they expected people to say no. If lots of people said yes, that meant that Vanessa's fears about rejection were misplaced. Her perception of the influence she actually had on other people was wrong. Like most of us, Vanessa had long felt that others had a big effect on her.
当她凝视着数据时，她意识到自己对其他人也有很大的影响。如果她对这种力量视而不见，会对她的行为产生什么影响呢？作为研究人员，凡妮莎和弗兰克决定要做的第一件事，就是检验他们的个人经历是否具有普遍性。我们决定把参与者带进实验室，让他们基本上做我那些天做过的事。所以我们把他们带进实验室。我们说，嘿，我们要让你去校园里让人家，作为我们的第一步，填一份调查问卷，就像我做过的那样。你认为会有多少人对你说“好”？我们让他们估计有多少人会同意，然后出去并真正去询问人们。
As she gazed at the data, she realized that she had a big effect on other people. If she was blind to this power, what consequences could it have on her behavior? As researchers, the first thing that Vanessa and Frank decided to do was test if their personal experience was generalizable. We decided to bring participants into the lab and have them do basically what I had done on those number of days. So we brought them into the lab. We said, hey, we're going to have you go out and ask people to, as our first step, fill out a survey, just like I had done. And how many people do you think are going to say yes to you? We made them estimate how many people they thought would agree, go out and actually ask people.
而我们发现的是，他们确实低估了会同意该请求的人数。所以这不仅仅是凡妮莎和弗兰克的问题。人们普遍对他们对他人影响力的评估较差。人们以为其他人会觉得拒绝他们的请求是一件很简单的事。凡妮莎将我们思维中的这个明显盲点
And what we found was that they really underestimated the number of people who would agree to that request. So it wasn't just Vanessa and Frank. People in general seem to have a poor assessment of their power over others. People thought that others would find it easy to turn down their requests. Vanessa connected the seeming blind spot in our thinking
与斯坦利·米尔格拉姆著名的服从研究联系了起来。她意识到，这可能就是为什么每个人总是从被要求施加电击的志愿者（即受到影响的人）的角度来看待实验的原因。没有人从主试（即施加影响力的人）的角度来看待实验。我们不会问，他发出那些疯狂的指令是否很困难，因为我们不会
to Stanley Milgram's famous obedience study. She realized this might be why everyone always saw the experiment from the perspective of the volunteers asked to administer shocks, the people being influenced. No one saw the experiment from the point of view of the experimenter, the person exercising influence. We don't ask, was it hard for him to issue those crazy instructions because we don't
把自己等同于行使这种影响力的人。我们认为那种人一定和我们非常不同，因为我们不觉得我们拥有这样的力量。看到这些人顺从他提出的这个疯狂要求，他会感到惊讶吗？所以，当人们想到斯坦利·米尔格拉姆的研究时，这很有趣，我想对我自己来说也是如此，我总是想象自己处于实验中志愿者的角色，听到来自……你知道的，主试的指令，说，你知道的，你必须电击另一个人。我从来没有把自己放在主试的位置，听到来自……你知道的，主试的指令，说，你知道的，你必须电击另一个人。我从来没有把自己放在主试的位置。
identify with people exercising such influence. We think that kind of person must be very different from us Because we don't feel we have such power was he surprised to see these people going along with this crazy request He was making of them. So it's interesting when people think about the Stanley Milgram study And I think this is true for myself as well I always imagined myself being in the role of the volunteer in the experiment hearing the instructions from you know The experiment are saying, you know, you must shock this other person. I never put myself in the shoes of the experiment, hearing the instructions from, you know, the experimenter saying, you know, you must shock this other person. I never put myself in the shoes of the experimenter.
没错，所以这是我们开始思考的一个问题。所以我们经常会进行某种模拟，如果我在那个米尔格拉姆电击实验中，如果我是研究参与者，我会怎么做？我真的会站出来违抗这些指令并说不吗？但我们把这个想法颠覆了。凡妮莎回想她在宾夕法尼亚车站的经历。这之所以觉得困难，是因为她
Exactly, so that was something that we started to wonder about. So we so often sort of simulate, if I was in that Milgram shock experiment, what would I do if I was the study participant, right? Would I actually stand up and go against these directives and say no? But we kind of flipped that idea on its head. Vanessa went back to her experience at Penn Station. It felt difficult because she had
仅仅从自己内心不安全感的角度来看待这次互动。她没有从她寻求帮助的人的角度来看待这些相遇。在他们看来，一个焦虑的年轻女性正在请求一些微不足道的事情。他们必须权衡是否要放下手头的事并帮她几分钟。如果他们拒绝，可能会显得他们很混蛋。这是一个非常有趣的现象：这两个人在互相互动，他们都太关注于他们自己的个人焦虑、不安全感和对尴尬的担忧，以至于他们没有意识到另一个人
seen the interaction only from the point of view of her own insecurities. She hadn't seen the encounters through the point of view of the people she was asking for help. From their perspective, an anxious young woman was asking for something trivial. They had to weigh whether to put aside what they were doing and help her for a few minutes. If they said no, it could make them look like jerks. It's this really interesting phenomenon where you have these two people interacting with one another and they're both so focused on their own personal anxieties and insecurities and concerns with embarrassment that they don't realize that the other person
也有这种感觉。所以这是一个非常有趣的情况：过度向内关注你自己的焦虑，会使你很难认清这种情境对其他人来说到底是什么样的。经历这些相遇的人会体验到心理学家所说的“自我中心偏差”。他们太全神贯注于自己的感知，以至于看不到这次互动对另一个人来说是什么感觉。诚然，我们许多人都受到情境的影响，我们许多人做某些事是因为情境促使我们这样做。但这里还有另一个问题，而且它
is feeling that way too. So it's this really interesting situation where being so inwardly focused on your own anxieties makes it so difficult for you to recognize what the situation really is for itself. People in these encounters experience what psychologists call an egocentric bias. They are so consumed with their own perceptions that they fail to see what the interaction feels like for the other person. It's absolutely true that many of us are influenced by situations that many of us will do things because the situation prompts it. But there is another problem too and it
可能是一个更深层的问题。把我们置于那些情境中的人，并不是什么全能的神。他们和我们一样是人类，他们可能没有意识到他们对我们的影响力有多大。事实上，他们可能在想：“我确信这个人会拒绝我的请求。”他们可能会错误地假设拒绝指令是很简单的。凡妮莎意识到，这种偏差可能会产生各种重要后果。因此，我们在大约十年前开始探讨的是，我们是否能认出当我们才是那个在影响别人的人时，
might be a deeper problem. The people who put us in those situations, it's not like they are all-powerful gods. They are humans just like us and they may not realize the extent of the power they have over us. In fact, they may be thinking, I'm sure this person is going to turn down my request. They might assume, falsely, that it's easy to refuse instructions. Vanessa realized that this bias could have all sorts of important consequences. So what we started looking at about over a decade now, ago, we started to look at whether we recognize when we're the ones who are influencing someone else,
当我们意识到其他人，例如，无法对我们提出的要求说不时。凡妮莎现在是康奈尔大学的心理学家。在一系列实验中，她证明了人们常常没有意识到自己对他人拥有的影响力。在一项研究中，她要求志愿者（主要是大学生）向他人提出一个简单的请求。我们把人们带进实验室，并告诉他们：“你们将去校园里，请别人借他们的手机。”她指导他们如何接近他人，并给他们指示，一旦人们同意让他们使用手机后该怎么做。他们会给我们实验室回电话，说“我拿到了这个人的手机，我现在的具体位置是……”，我们会记录下来，然后他们再去问另一个人。在志愿者出去开始
when we recognize that someone else, for example, can't say no to something that we've asked them. Vanessa is now a psychologist at Cornell University. In a series of experiments, she has demonstrated how people are often oblivious to the power that they have over others. In one study, she asked volunteers, mostly college students, to make a simple request of others. We brought people into the lab and we told them, you're going to go out into campus and ask people to borrow their phones. She walked them through how to approach someone and gave them instructions for what to do once people agree to let them use their phones. They would call us back at the lab and say I have this person's phone, this is where I'm located, we'd mark it down and then they go on and ask somebody else. Before the volunteers went out to begin the
研究之前，凡妮莎问了他们一个问题。为了让三个人说“好”，他们必须问多少人？在这个时候，参与者对整个想法感到有点惊慌。他们确信每个人都会说不。他们将无法完成任务。在他们真正去校园执行任务之前，他们经常会问我们：“如果没有人同意怎么办？我要回来吗？”
study, Vanessa asked them a question. How many people would they have to ask to get three people to say yes? And at this time, participants are kind of freaked out by this whole thought. They are convinced everyone's going to say no. They're not going to be able to do the task. And before they actually go out onto campus to do the task, they often would ask us, well, what if no one agrees? Do I come back?
“我该怎么办？”他们对无法完成任务有着各种各样的担忧。凡妮莎发现的情况与她在宾夕法尼亚车站的亲身经历相似。说“好”的人比志愿者预期的要多得多。他们以为自己必须问十多个人才行。实际上他们只需要问六个人左右。
What do I do? They have all these concerns about not being able to complete the task. What Vanessa found was similar to her own experience at Penn Station. Many more people said yes than the volunteers expected. They thought they had to ask a little over 10. They actually had to ask more like six.
事实上，每隔一个人就会同意这个请求。也许你认为学生们有很高的成功率是因为他们请求的事微不足道。但凡妮莎也进行过另一个版本的实验，其中志愿者必须要求更具实质性的东西——钱。对于那项研究，她争取到了白血病和淋巴瘤协会“团队训练”项目的帮助。
In fact, every other person was agreeing to this request. Maybe you think the students had a high success rate because they were requesting something trivial. But Vanessa has also conducted a version of the study where volunteers had to ask for something more consequential, money. For that study, she enlisted the help of the leukemia and lymphoma societies team in training program.
人们参加“团队训练”等筹款活动时会做的是，他们向人们请求捐款，以便他们能够参加铁人三项或马拉松等某种比赛。他们会获得一些训练和一些差旅费来做到这一点，其余的钱实际上会捐给组织。凡妮莎询问参与者，为了达到筹款目标（通常是数千美元），他们必须向多少人募捐。他们估计需要询问大约200人才能达到目标。我们发现，实际上他们只需要问这个数字的一半左右。
What people do when they participate in a fundraising activity for team in training is they ask people for donations so that they can participate in some sort of race like a triathlon or a marathon. They get some training and some travel money to be able to do that and the rest of the money actually goes to the organization. Vanessa asked participants how many people they would have to solicit to meet their fundraising goals, which were typically thousands of dollars. They estimated they would need to ask about 200 people to meet the goal. What we found is that they actually only had to ask about half that.
所以为了达到筹款目标，他们只需询问大约100人即可。正如在凡妮莎的手机研究中一样，她的参与者将他们以为为了达到目标必须询问的人数翻了一番。他们的自我中心偏差导致他们过度关注自己的焦虑，从而忽视了他们对他人实际产生的影响。你在考虑你的请求。我在向这个人要钱。这个人会给我钱吗？你没有做的是去考虑如果你坐在那里，你知道的，潜在地
So they only had to ask about 100 people in order to reach their fundraising goals. Just as in Vanessa's phone study, her participants doubled the number of people they thought they had to ask to reach their goal. Their egocentric bias caused them to focus so much on their own anxieties that they ignored the influence they actually had over other people. You're thinking about what you're asking. I'm asking this person for money. Will this person give me money? What you're not doing is thinking about what if you were sitting there, you know, potentially in
因此，他们只需询问大约100人就能达到筹款目标。正如在瓦妮莎的电话研究中一样，她的参与者认为自己必须询问的人数是实际达到目标所需人数的两倍。他们的自我中心偏差导致他们过度关注自己的焦虑，从而忽略了他们对其他人实际产生的影响。你在考虑你所提出的要求。我在向这个人要钱。这个人会给我钱吗？而你没有做的是去思考，如果你坐在那里，你知道的，可能会处于
your cubicle and a co-worker came up to you and said, hey, I'm participating in a race, would you be willing to sponsor me? If you were sitting there, it'd be really hard to say no to your coworker, right? It'd be really hard to let them down, it'd be really awkward, what would you even say? And so people are kind of put on the spot and they find it really difficult to say no, so they go ahead and agree. At the University of Chicago, economist John List has also studied the relationship between social pressure and charitable giving.
你的隔壁工位，一个同事走过来对你说：“嘿，我正在参加一场长跑比赛，你愿意资助我吗？”如果你当时坐在那里，其实很难对同事说不，对吧？要拒绝他们真的很让人难堪，气氛会变得非常尴尬，你甚至不知道该说些什么？因此，人们常常被架在那个位置上，发现拒绝真的很难，于是就顺水推舟地答应了。在芝加哥大学，经济学家约翰·李斯特（John List）也对社会压力与慈善捐赠之间的关系进行了研究。
John ran a study where experimenters knocked on the doors of some 8000 houses in the Chicago area. They were trying to raise money for a children's hospital. John asked me to imagine the scenario from the point of view of the person receiving the request. Let's say it's a Sunday afternoon. I've just made myself something to eat. I'm relaxed. You're sitting on the couch watching a football game and you hear somebody knocking on the
约翰进行了一项研究，实验人员敲响了芝加哥地区大约 8000 户家庭的门。他们试图为一家儿童医院筹集资金。约翰让我从接受请求的人的角度来想象这个场景。假设现在是一个星期天的下午。我刚刚给自己弄了点吃的。我很放松。你正坐在沙发上看一场橄榄球比赛，然后你听到有人在敲
door and you think okay should I get up or should I stay watching the football games of course a lot of people get up and answer the door but once they see that there's a solicitor at the door they say oh my god I wish I would have stayed on the couch watching the football game too late if they tell the solicitor no, then they have this very negative or disutility from letting someone down. So they're weighing that off versus just giving them $20 and having them go on their way. John added a very interesting twist to the study. Some households were told ahead of time
门，你心想，好吧，我是该起来开门呢，还是继续看橄榄球比赛？当然，很多人会起身去开门，但当他们发现门外是个募捐员时，他们就会想：“天哪，我真希望自己刚才一直呆在沙发上看橄榄球赛就好了。”但为时已晚。如果他们拒绝募捐员，就会因为让别人失望而产生强烈的负面情绪或心理效用损失。所以，他们正在权衡这种心理成本与直接捐出 20 美元然后打发对方离开哪个更划算。约翰为这项研究增添了一个非常有趣的变化。一些家庭提前得到了通知，
that a fundraising volunteer would come and knock on the door. Others were not told ahead of time. They just received an unexpected knock. What we find is that when we warn them, of course, many people just stay on the couch or they leave the house. They never answer the door. The people who do answer the door, they do tend to give money. And much of that is because of altruistic reasons.
知道会有募捐志愿者来敲门。而另一些家庭则没有提前得到通知。他们只是迎来了意料之外的敲门声。我们发现，当我们提前发出警告时，当然，许多人就会选择呆在沙发上或者离开房子。他们根本不会去开门。而那些确实去开门的人，他们往往会捐钱。其中很大一部分原因是为了利他主义。
But the people who we do not warn, they end up answering the door more often, and they give more. Put another way, people understand how they are going to feel when they're put on the spot. They often will go to great lengths to avoid getting in such situations. What this also means is that some significant portion of the money that charities raise might not come from altruism. In the case of the Children's Hospital fundraiser,
但是，对于那些我们没有发出警告的人，他们最终开门的频率更高，而且捐出的钱也更多。换句话说，人们很清楚当自己被当场架住时会有什么感觉。他们常常会想方设法避免陷入这种境地。这也意味着，慈善机构筹集的大部分资金可能并非源于利他主义。以儿童医院的募捐活动为例，
for example, what you find is that roughly three-quarters of the dollars given are due to social pressure and a quarter of the dollars given is actually due to altruism. So a very small component of what we observe in our door-to-door fundraising drive is actually driven by altruism. John's research reminds Vanessa of a classic study where researchers set up two booths on a college campus. One booth was clearly asking people for something, while the other did not ask for anything. What the researchers found was similar to John's donation study.
举个例子，你会发现大约四分之三的捐款是由于社会压力，而只有四分之一的捐款实际上是由于利他主义。因此，在我们上门募捐活动中观察到的现象，其实只有极小一部分是由利他主义驱动的。约翰的研究让凡妮莎想起了一项经典研究：研究人员在大学校园里设立了两个摊位。其中一个摊位明确在向人们索取东西，而另一个摊位则什么也没要求。研究人员发现的结果与约翰的捐赠研究相似。
They measured how far away people walked from the booth as they walked by this path. And if people knew that they were going to be asked for something, their distance from the booth was much further than if they didn't think they were going to be asked for something. We just kind of avoid any chance of having to say no to somebody. We've seen how egocentric bias can cause us to act in helpful ways to others. We lend phones to people who need them or donate money to charity. Unfortunately though, there's another side to the story. They grabbed that headset and they threw it across the room. When we come back, the sinister side of our inability to recognize our power over other people. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
他们测量了人们路过这条小路时，距离摊位有多远。如果人们知道自己会被索要东西，他们与摊位的距离就会比以为自己不会被索要东西时远得多。我们只是在某种程度上避免任何不得不拒绝别人的机会。我们已经看到自我中心偏见如何导致我们以对他人有帮助的方式行事。我们把手机借给需要的人，或者向慈善机构捐款。但不幸的是，事情还有另一面。他们抓起那副耳机，把它扔过了房间。稍后回来，我们将探讨我们无法认识到自己对他人拥有权力的阴暗面。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。
When we interact with others, we are often intensely focused on how we feel. Our anxieties, our embarrassments, our fears. As a result, we are often blind to the effect we have on others, their anxieties, their embarrassments, and their fears. Psychologist Vanessa Bonds has studied how such egocentric bias can keep people from asking for help. But that's not the whole story. There's kind of the happy story, which is that people will help us more than we think, and then there's kind of the darker story that people will do a lot of other things for us more so than we think.
当我们与他人互动时，我们常常高度关注自己的感受。我们的焦虑、我们的尴尬、我们的恐惧。因此，我们往往对我们对他人产生的影响视而不见，对他们的焦虑、他们的尴尬和他们的恐惧也同样如此。心理学家凡妮莎·邦兹（Vanessa Bohns）研究了这种自我中心偏见如何阻止人们寻求帮助。但事实并非全部。这里有一种美好的故事，也就是人们给予我们的帮助比我们想象的要多；然后还有一种相对黑暗的故事，那就是人们会为我们做很多其他事情，这也比我们想象的要多。
So we've run some studies where we started out kind of asking people if they could get someone to lie for them. So our original studies involved just filling something out. We said, what if we just have them ask if they'll sign their name to something saying that you gave them a pitch that you didn't actually give them,
所以我们做了一些研究，最初是问人们是否能让某人为他们说谎。所以我们最初的研究只涉及填写一些东西。我们说，如果我们让他们询问是否愿意在一份声明上签名，证明你做过他们实际上并未做过的推销，会怎么样？
just kind of a white lie. And so once again, we had people guess how many people they would have to make this request of before a certain number said yes. They went out onto campus, they asked people, you know, I'm supposed to be doing this pitch. I really don't feel like doing it. Will you just sign this saying that I gave you the pitch?
这只是一种善意的谎言。因此，我们再次让人们猜测，在一定数量的人说“好”之前，他们必须向多少人提出这个请求。他们走到校园里，问人们，你知道的，我应该做一个推销。我真的不想做。你能在上面签个字，证明我向你做过推销吗？
And again, most people wound up signing it, even though our participants thought that most people would say no. As Vanessa says, the volunteers were asking people to tell a trivial lie. And perhaps you could say, what's the big deal in signing a note that says, someone gave you a pitch that they didn't? There are no real moral consequences. So Vanessa raised the stakes. So what we did is we created these fake library books.
同样，大多数人都签了字，尽管我们的参与者以为大多数人会说“不”。正如凡妮莎所说，志愿者是在请求人们说一个微不足道的谎言。也许你会说，在一张便条上签名算什么大不了的，上面写着别人向你做过你其实没听过的推销？这并没有真正的道德后果。所以凡妮莎提高了赌注。所以我们做的是，我们制作了这些假的图书馆书籍。
We took a bunch of books off my bookshelf and just, you know, put some library codes on them. And we gave them to participants and we said, we're going to have you go into the libraries on campus and ask people to vandalize these library books. And so they were to tell people, I'm playing a prank on my friend, but they know my handwriting. Will you please just write Pickle in this library book in pen? And they left it at that and looked at whether or not people agreed. And what we found is that the people they approached, so they kept track of sort of the things that people said when they made this request of them, and people would say things like, this is wrong.
我们从我的书架上拿了一堆书，然后，你知道的，在上面贴了一些图书馆编码。我们把它们交给参与者，并对他们说，我们要让你们去校园里的图书馆，要求人们破坏这些图书馆图书。他们要对人们说，我在对我的朋友搞恶作剧，但他们认得我的字迹。请你用笔在这本图书馆的书上写下“泡菜”这个词好吗？他们就说到这里，然后看人们是否同意。我们发现的是，他们接触的人——他们记录了人们在听到这个请求时所说的话——人们会说这样的话：“这不对。”
You shouldn't be doing this. We could get in trouble. They were clearly uncomfortable with the prospect of vandalizing this purported library book. People would say things like, this is wrong, you shouldn't be doing this, we could get in trouble. They were clearly uncomfortable with the prospect of vandalizing this purported library book, but they still did it. They still did it. And again, that finding went completely against the intuitions of the volunteers doing the asking. People significantly underestimated how much influence they possessed to get others
“你不应该这样做。我们会有麻烦的。”他们对破坏这本所谓的图书馆书籍的前景显然感到不自在。人们会说这样的话：“这不对，你不应该这样做，我们会有麻烦的。”他们对破坏这本所谓的图书馆书籍的前景显然感到不自在，但他们还是照做了。他们还是照做了。而且，这一发现完全违背了提出要求的志愿者的直觉。人们严重低估了自己拥有的影响力，无法预料自己能让其他人
to do something unethical. So our participants, before they went out and started asking people, they thought about 28% of people would agree to do this, right? So they thought the vast majority of people would say no. But when they actually went out and made this request of people, 64%, a majority of the people they asked actually agreed to vandalize this library book. I mean, that's actually pretty astonishing that 64% of people would say yes. I mean, I would not have predicted it would be as high a number as that.
去做不道德的事情。所以我们的参与者在走出去开始请求别人之前，他们认为大约 28% 的人会同意这样做，对吧？所以他们认为绝大多数人会说“不”。但当他们真正走出去向人们提出这个请求时，64% 的被请求者——也就是大多数人——竟然同意破坏这本图书馆书籍。我的意思是，64% 的人会说“好”，这其实相当令人震惊。我的意思是，我绝对不会预料到数字会这么高。
Yeah. I mean, this was a task we designed and we were like, this is never going to work, right? There's no way people are actually going to agree to do this. And we ourselves were completely surprised that people did agree. As much as it was uncomfortable for them to do this unethical thing and vandalize a library book, it was way more uncomfortable for them to say no to the person who was asking. The scenarios in which egocentric bias could play a role in our behavior seem endless.
是的。我的意思是，这是我们设计的一项任务，当时我们还想：“这绝对行不通，对吧？人们根本不可能同意这么做。”而我们自己也对人们竟然同意了感到十分震惊。尽管做这件不道德的事、破坏图书馆书本让他们感到不舒服，但对拒绝提出请求的人说“不”，对他们来说要难受得多。自我中心偏见可能在我们的行为中发挥作用的场景似乎无穷无尽。
We share the answers to our homework with a friend who asks to see our work. We don't push back when a colleague suggests bending the rules on a time sheet. We agree to keep a friend's infidelity a secret, even when it makes us uncomfortable. Listening to Vanessa made me realize why there is a vast gulf between what we predict we might do and what we actually do when we are confronted with problematic behavior. We look as outsiders at the situation and we say, why would you tolerate this?
我们把家庭作业的答案分享给要求查看我们作业的朋友。当同事建议在工时表上变通规则时，我们不会进行回击。我们同意为朋友的不忠行为保密，即使这让我们感到不舒服。听了凡妮莎的话，我意识到为什么在我们预测自己可能会做什么与面对问题行为时实际会做什么之间，存在着巨大的鸿沟。我们作为局外人审视这种情况，然后会说：“你为什么要容忍这种事？”
Why wouldn't you just stand up and say, I'm not going to do this, I'm not going to hurt another person? I need to be able to do my job and you're affecting my ability to do my job. But in fact, the social pressure, the concern about offending another person, the social anxiety in that situation is so palpable to that individual that it feels almost impossible for them to stand up and say something about it
“你为什么不直接站出来说，‘我不会这么做，我不会伤害另一个人？我需要能够完成我的工作，而你正在影响我完成工作能力’？”但事实上，社会压力、对冒犯他人的担忧、那种情境下的社交焦虑对那个人来说是如此真切，以至于他们觉得几乎不可能站出来说些什么
and reject the sort of behavior that they're encountering. Hidden brain listener Anna Aburuz called in with a story that illustrates how egocentric bias can affect workplace behavior. She was training to be an air traffic controller and saw examples of bullying and harassing behavior all around her. She says the trainers had a clear message for trainees. Don't be soft or you know you got to have thick skin to survive in air traffic. That was a common one for sure. You have to have thick skin to survive in air traffic.
并拒绝他们所遭遇的那种行为。《隐藏的大脑》听众安娜·阿布鲁兹（Anna Aburuz）打来电话，讲述了一个说明自我中心偏见如何影响工作场所行为的故事。她当时正在接受空中交通管制员的培训，周围到处都是霸凌和骚扰行为的例子。她说，培训师对学员有一个明确的信息：“不要表现得软弱，你知道，要想在航空管制领域生存下去，你必须脸皮厚。”这绝对是常见的一句。你必须脸皮厚才能在航空管制领域生存下来。
I've heard that over a hundred times. Anna recalled one painful incident. There was a trainee that was trying to clear an aircraft for landing. And the trainer in that moment grabbed the headset of the trainee and this headset is plugged in to the radar and they grabbed that headset and they threw it across the room which would fly off of the head of the trainee. They would actually tell them, hey hurry up and go grab it so that you can plug back in and clear this aircraft for landing. Anna says seeing such incidents made her fearful. She didn't feel she could complain, since
这样的话我听过不下上百次。安娜回忆起了一起痛苦的事件。当时有一名学员正试图指挥一架飞机降落。那一刻，培训师抓住了学员的耳机——这个耳机是连在雷达上的——他们抓起那个耳机，把它扔过了房间，耳机直接从学员的头上飞了出去。他们甚至会对他们说：“嘿，快点去捡回来，这样你才能重新插上并指挥这架飞机降落。”安娜说，看到这样的事件让她感到恐惧。她觉得她不能抱怨，因为
such behaviors appear to be the norm. Who could she complain to? The people who were themselves acting badly. They would just say things like what are you doing if you do that again I swear to God. One time when she was directing aircraft this was in real life not a simulation she found herself sitting next to one of the trainers who she says had acted abusively to our trainees. By this point Anna was no longer a trainee. She was directing two aircraft. One was a thousand feet above the other. I got the names of the of the aircraft mixed up and I because I was so nervous I think and I descended the wrong aircraft. I descended the one on top instead of the one on the bottom because
这些行为似乎已经成了常态。她能向谁抱怨呢？那些本身行为就很恶劣的人。他们只会说类似这样的话：“你在干什么？如果你再这样做，我向天发誓……”有一次，当她在指挥飞机时——这是在现实生活中，而不是模拟器中——她发现自己坐在其中一位培训师旁边，据她说，这位培训师曾对学员有虐待行为。此时的安娜已经不再是学员了。她在指挥两架飞机。一架在另一架上方一千英尺。我把这两架飞机的代号弄混了，因为我太紧张了，我想，我让错误的飞机下降了。我让上面那架飞机下降了，而不是下面那架，因为
I got those call signs messed up. She told the aircraft that was at a higher altitude to descend directly into the path of the lower altitude aircraft. Luckily the pilot could see the aircraft so the pilot was just, no, we're not going to descend. And I immediately knew what I had just done. And I thought, today was a clear day. It was clear skies. There was no clouds in the way. There wasn't any storm clouds in the way. But had there been storm clouds, or had there
我把那些呼号搞混了。她告诉飞行高度较高的飞机直接下降，飞入飞行高度较低的飞机的航线上。幸运的是，飞行员能看到那架飞机，所以飞行员直接说：“不，我们不下降。”我立刻意识到我刚刚做了什么。我想，那天是个好天气。天高云淡。没有云彩挡路。也没有任何暴风雨云挡路。但如果有暴风雨云，或者有
been some other kind of visual obstruction, this plane would have descended and they would have hit that aircraft and I would have been responsible for hundreds of deaths. And it wasn't because I didn't know how to control the traffic, I did. And I had done this a million times. It was because of the social stress that I was in at that time
其他某种视觉障碍，这架飞机就会下降并撞上那架飞机，而我将为数百人的死亡负责。这不是因为我不知道如何管制交通，我懂得。而且我已经这样做过无数次了。这是因为当时我所处的社会压力
that didn't make me think clearly. I told Vanessa Barnes what Anna described, how the mere presence of the trainer had disrupted her to the point where she made a mistake that could have been catastrophic. Vanessa said, look, it's certainly the case that there are lots of unethical people who know they are unethical and lots of bullies who know they are bullies. Maybe that was the case here. But there is a deeper problem in the workplace that we often forget. The bullies and harassers who don't know that they are bullies and harassers. Often, when we're the person causing someone else distress, we can't see that distress. It's invisible to us.
让我无法清晰地思考。我把安娜所描述的情况告诉了凡妮莎·邦兹：培训师的存在是如何干扰她到让她犯下可能造成灾难性后果的错误。凡妮莎说，看，当然有很多不道德的人知道自己不道德，也有很多恶霸知道自己是恶霸。也许这里的情况就是这样。但在工作场所中，有一个我们经常忘记的更深层次的问题。那些不知道自己是恶霸和骚扰者的恶霸和骚扰者。通常，当我们是给他人带来痛苦的人时，我们却看不到这种痛苦。这对我们来说是隐形的。
And it's not to let anybody off the hook, because clearly it's the people creating this toxic culture's responsibility to kind of fix it and to not cause these things to happen. But there's also this cognitive bias there where we may not realize the extent to which we're interfering with somebody else's performance. These same dynamics play out in another common occurrence in the workplace, unwanted romantic attention. We ran a couple of studies where we asked people about their experiences being asked out at work or asking someone out at work. And we ask people to imagine situations where they weren't interested in the other person or the other person wasn't interested in them.
这并不是为了给任何人开脱，因为显然修复这种有毒文化、不让这些事情发生，是创造这种文化的人的责任。但那里也存在这种认知偏差，我们可能没有意识到自己在多大程度上干扰了别人的表现。同样的动态也在工作场所的另一个常见现象中上演——不受欢迎的浪漫关注。我们进行了一些研究，询问人们在工作中被邀约或在工作约别人的经历。我们让人们想象那些他们对对方不感兴趣，或者对方对他们不感兴趣的情境。
And what we found is that people who asked somebody out at work and were rejected thought that it was pretty easy for that person to reject them, right? They didn't think that that person experienced a whole lot of distress and they didn't think that they changed their behavior very much after being asked out. But when people recalled situations where they were asked out by someone at work who they weren't interested in, they described feeling obligated to say yes, feeling much
我们发现，在工作中约了别人却被拒绝的人认为，对方拒绝他们其实挺容易的，对吧？他们不认为对方经历了很多痛苦，也不认为对方在被邀约后改变了多少行为。但当人们回忆起在工作中被自己不感兴趣的人约过的情景时，他们形容自己感到了说“好的”义务，对向对方说“不”感到
more uncomfortable saying no to the person, and they reported doing all sorts of things to try to avoid that person that the other person didn't realize that they were doing. So in fact, this little request, we tell people to just go for it and ask this person out. It actually puts a lot more pressure on the other person than we tend to realize when we're the ones doing the asking. In some ways, we underestimate the pressure that we exert on other people. In some ways, that's the moral of the whole story here, isn't it?
更加不舒服，并且他们报告说自己做了各种各样的尝试来避开那个人，而对方根本没有意识到他们在这么做。因此，事实上，这个小小的请求——我们告诉人们勇敢去约这个人吧——实际上给对方施加了比我们作为发起者所意识到的要大得多的压力。在某些方面，我们低估了我们对他人施加的压力。从某种意义上说，这就是整个故事的寓意，不是吗？
Absolutely, yeah. We underestimate the influence that we have over other people, and we underestimate the extent to which asking them for something really puts them in an awkward position, because now they have to say no, and that's just a really hard thing for people to do. Like many psychological biases, the tendency we have to downplay the influence we have on others can have far-reaching consequences. It can keep us from asking for help that would be forthcoming. It can keep us from reaching out and making friends with strangers. And it can also lead us to give in to unethical demands or make improper demands of other people. I asked Vanessa how her research had prompted her
绝对是的。我们低估了我们对其他人的影响力，并且我们低估了向他们索取东西确实把他们置于一个尴尬境地的程度，因为现在他们必须说“不”，而这对于人们来说真的是一件很难做到的事情。就像许多心理偏差一样，我们淡化对他人影响力的倾向会产生深远的影响。它会阻止我们寻求本可以得到的帮助。它会阻止我们主动与陌生人交往并结交朋友。它还会导致我们向不道德的要求妥协，或者对他人提出不当的要求。我问凡妮莎她的研究是如何促使她
to do things differently in her own life. It has made a huge difference in the little things. So for example, when I was pregnant, if I needed a seat on the subway or on a train, I would kind of stand there and look around and try to look my most pathetic so that someone would give me their seat, thinking that someone would step up and do it because they were nice, right?
在自己的生活中做出改变的。它在生活中的小事上带来了巨大的改变。例如，当我怀孕时，如果我需要在地铁或火车上找个座位，我就会站在那里四处张望，尽量让自己看起来最可怜，好让别人把座位让给我，心想别人会因为善良而主动站出来让座，对吧？
But in fact, everyone's all involved in their own stuff. They're not necessarily looking around and paying attention. And maybe they'd be perfectly happy to give up their seat, but they're not going to think of it unless you actually ask. And so I tried to take that into account. So when I was pregnant, I would go up to people and be like, hey, can I sit down? I'd really love to sit.
但事实上，每个人都沉浸在自己的事情中。他们不一定在环顾四周并留意这些。也许他们非常乐意让出座位，但除非你真的开口要求，否则他们不会想到这一点。所以，我试着把这一点考虑进去。因此，当我怀孕时，我会走到别人面前说：“嘿，我能坐一下吗？我很想坐一会儿。”
And then, of course, people are incredibly happy to just pop up and say yes. And what's interesting, of course, is when that happens, you're actually giving people an opportunity to do something nice. It's not just that you're imposing on them. Presumably, some of them are actually happy to say, I was just writing to work and now I actually got to do this nice thing
然后，当然，人们会非常乐意地一下子站起来说“好”。而有趣的是，当然，当这种情况发生时，你实际上是给了人们一个做好事的机会。这不仅仅是你强加于他们。据推测，他们中的一些人实际上很高兴地说：“我只是在通勤上班，现在我居然能为另一个人做这件好事。”
for this other person. I feel this little warm glow. Yeah, absolutely. So a lot of people wonder about the takeaway. So if people agree to help us out of obligation because they feel like they can't say no, then do you really want to ask them for things? But people are really good at justifying their behaviors
我感到了微微的暖意。是的，绝对是这样。所以很多人都在想结论是什么。如果人们因为觉得自己无法拒绝而出于义务同意帮忙，那你真的想向他们寻求帮助吗？但人们非常擅长为自己的行为辩护，
and ways that make them feel good about themselves. So they may agree to help because they feel like they can't say no, but pretty quickly after that, they're going to be convincing themselves that they helped because they're a really wonderful person. And so everyone's going to walk away feeling good about the interaction.
用能让他们对自己感觉良好的方式。因此，他们可能会因为觉得自己无法拒绝而同意帮忙，但在那之后不久，他们就会说服自己，他们帮忙是因为他们是个非常棒的人。于是每个人都会带着对这次互动的美好感觉离开。
You got the help that you needed and the other person gets to feel like a good person. Psychologists once conducted a light-hearted version of Stanley Milgram's Obedience Study. In the 1970s, they had research assistants stand on the streets of New York City. Their jobs? To look skyward. At nothing. The question the researchers wanted to know was whether innocent passers-by would also stop to look up to see what was going on. They found that when more people were in on the gag, more pedestrians stopped and looked up.
你得到了你需要的帮助，而另一个人也得以觉得自己是个好人。心理学家曾经进行过一个轻松版本的斯坦利·米尔格拉姆服从实验。在 20 世纪 70 年代，他们让研究助理站在纽约市的街头。他们的工作是什么？抬头望向天空。看着虚无。研究人员想要探究的问题是，无辜的过路人是否也会停下来抬头看看究竟发生了什么。他们发现，当更多的人加入这个恶作剧时，更多的行人停了下来并抬头张望。
I've seen video of that study many times and always found this scene funny. One to fifteen people just staring off into the sky. Recently I rewatched it and this time I did what Vanessa had done. I flipped the script. Instead of seeing the experiment from the point of view of the passersby and asking myself whether I would be similarly influenced, I looked at the experiment from the point of view of the research assistants. Did they expect so many people to join them in looking at nothing? We've seen throughout this episode how all of us as individuals have great power to shape how others behave. If each of us has this hidden power, then collectively, as groups, as communities, as tribes,
我看过那个研究的视频很多次，并且一直觉得这个场景很搞笑。一十五个人只是盯着天空发呆。最近我重温了一遍，这次我做了凡妮莎做过的事。我颠覆了剧本。我没有从路人的角度来看待这个实验，也没有问自己是否会受到同样的启发，而是从研究助理的角度来看待这个实验。他们曾预料到会有这么多人加入他们一起仰望虚空吗？我们在这一集的节目中看到，我们作为个人，都拥有巨大的力量来塑造他人的行为。如果我们每个人都拥有这种隐藏的力量，那么作为一个集体、作为社区、作为群体，
we are going to have even more influence. How we choose to use that influence? That's up to each of us. HIDDEN BRAIN is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brains executive editor. We end today with a story from our sister show, My Unsung Hero. It's brought to you by T-Mobile for Business. Our story comes from Bethany Renfri.
我们将拥有更大的影响力。我们如何选择使用这种影响力？这取决于我们每个人。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。今天我们将以来自我们姐妹节目《我无名的英雄》的一个故事结束。本节目由 T-Mobile 商业版为您倾情呈现。我们的故事来自贝瑟尼·伦弗鲁。
I was 20 years old. My baby girls and I were living in low-income apartments. Most of my neighbors were single mothers like myself. And I remember how overwhelmed I felt that morning. It was a cold day in the apartment. I dragged myself to the sink and it was stacked with dishes with pots and pans that had been soaking because I'd burnt them all. I didn't know how to cook back then, and I would always burn our pans. And I looked at my twin girls. They were 18 months old. They sat in their high chairs.
我当时 20 岁。我的小女儿和我住在低收入公寓里。我的大多数邻居都和我一样是单身母亲。我记得那天早晨我感到多么不知所措。公寓里天气很冷。我拖着沉重的步伐走到水槽前，里面堆满了盘子，还有泡在水里的锅碗瓢盆，因为我都把它们烧焦了。我那时不会做饭，而且总是把锅烧糊。我看着我的双胞胎女儿。她们当时 18 个月大。她们坐在高脚椅上。
The baby, the newborn was in her swing. I looked back at the sink, and I just couldn't bring myself to do those dishes, and I couldn't look at them any longer. It was a reminder of how overwhelmed I felt in my own life. So I grabbed a white garbage bag and I stacked the dishes in there one by one. I walked out in the rain and I placed it on the edge of the apartment dumpster
那个婴儿，刚出生的婴儿正在秋千上。我回头看着水槽，就是无法让自己去洗那些盘子，我也再也无法直视它们了。这是对我在自己生活中感到多么不知所措的一种提醒。所以我抓起一个白色的垃圾袋，把盘子一个接一个地叠放在里面。我走进雨中，把它放在公寓垃圾箱的边缘，
because the dumpster was full. And I came back in and the girls and I left for the day. When I got back that evening, it was dark and my porch was dark because I didn't even have the energy to change the porch light. But as we were coming in, I kind of kicked something. It was a box. And so I brought it into the apartment and put it on the table and it was my pots and pans and they were shining and sparkling,
因为垃圾箱已经满了。然后我走回屋里，孩子们和我出门了一整天。当我那天晚上回来时，天已经黑了，我的门廊也很黑，因为我甚至没有精力去换门廊的灯泡。但当我们走进去时，我似乎踢到了什么东西。那是一个盒子。所以我把它拿进公寓放在桌子上，那是我的锅碗瓢盆，它们亮晶晶、闪闪发光，
and the girls' Blue's Clues plates and their sippy cups, and a little handwritten note popped out on a yellow piece of paper, and it said, I've been there before, you will make it, I promise you. I don't know which of the single mothers went out there that day and saw that garbage bag and understood what was happening.
还有女孩们的《蓝猫淘气三千问》盘子和她们的学饮杯，一张黄色纸片上弹出了一张手写的小纸条，上面写着：“我以前也经历过，你会挺过去的，我向你保证。”我不知道哪位单身母亲那天走出去看到了那个垃圾袋并理解了发生了什么。
But if I saw her today, I would thank her for showing me that we are not alone and we are not bad mothers, even in our hardest moments. We are surrounded by kindness and understanding and I'm so grateful to have learned that lesson so early on in motherhood. Bethany Renfrew lives in Sutter Creek, California. When she was 27, she went back to school and earned undergraduate and master's degrees. She is now a legislative director in the California State Senate. Today's My Unsung Hero story was brought to you by T-Mobile for Business.
但如果我今天见到她，我会感谢她向我展示了我们并不孤单，我们也不是糟糕的母亲，即使在我们最艰难的时刻。我们被善良和理解所包围，我很感激能在为人母的初期就学到这一课。贝瑟尼·伦弗鲁住在加利福尼亚州萨特克里克。在她 27 岁时，她重返校园，获得了本科和硕士学位。她现在是加利福尼亚州参议院的立法总监。今天的《我无名的英雄》故事由 T-Mobile 商业版为您呈现。
If you enjoy Hidden Brain, please take a moment and share your favorite episode with two or three people in your life. Word of mouth recommendations really make a huge difference in introducing new listeners to our work. We truly appreciate your support. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢《隐藏的大脑》，请花一点时间与你生活中的两三个人分享你最喜欢的剧集。口碑推荐确实对向新听众介绍我们的工作起到了巨大的作用。我们由衷地感谢您的支持。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。我们回头见。本集节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。